il y à des célébrations de victoire qui
cache des réalités plus complexe le
rassemblement national de marine le pen
n'a même pas un point d'avancé sur les
troupes du président emmanuel macron et
pourtant cette mobilisation
il est dit dans une élection européenne
depuis plus de 25 ans témoigne d'un
sursaut populaire contre le pouvoir en
place qui subissent ce soir véritable
échec
ceux qui ont terminé second en france ne
parle pas trop besoin d'ajuster les
politiques du gouvernement
et pourtant l'ombre des gilets jaunes
plainte toujours serait manuel mc ren
s'il avait gagné
même avec une courte majorité il faut
dire que finalement la sortie de crise
le débat national
les propositions ont été validées par
les français là on a plutôt un emmanuel
macron qui ne peut pas tourner la page
et passer à autre chose il va devoir
continuer à gérer une situation avec de
l'impopularité wii va user royaume uni
un parti qui désirent quitter l'union
européenne enverra une trentaine d'élus
au parlement européen se nomme à voter
pour eux audi compte comme on est
dégoûtés par l'attitude du gouvernement
britannique et de l'opposition
officielle en italie
la lega populiste arrive largement en
tête vos colis porto est une bouffée
d'air frais sur matteo salvini la
naissance d'une nouvelle europe qui
départ des forces populistes
sauf que sur le continent les partis de
droite radicale non pas réaliser les
percées anticipé avec des gains parfois
surprenants les verts sont aussi en
bonne position pour influencer l'agenda
propre et climats chauds tss réélu cet
eurodéputé allemand anticipe un
parlement plus enclins à la lutte contre
les changements climatiques
aucun parti n'est majoritaire dans ce
nouveau parlement ce qui fait que pour
gouverner
les centristes devront se trouver des
alliés chez des partis aux intérêts
parfois divergents
un jeu d'alliances qui ne s'est pas vu
en 40 ans ici un examen baron
radio-canada paris